il faut que nous soyons le plus proche
possible des des citoyens
bienvenue à cette salle de la halle aux
blés salle emblématique de tous une
gauche qui existe depuis 1850 au début
c'était un endroit où les paysans à
mener leur récolte tout le nom salle de
la halle au blé et puis petit à petit
c'est venu c'est devenu un lieu qui
rassemble plus largement tous les gens
tous les to les sundgauviens avec
notamment au xxème siècle une vocation
politique puisque de nombreux débats ont
eu lieu dans cette salle et puis une
salle de banquet et ça où les gens se
rassemblent et maintenant depuis peu une
salle à vocation plus culturel puisqu'il
y à de nombreux spectacles qui sont
organisées je vous cache pas que je me
suis posé quelques questions quant au
sens de mon engagement à un moment donné
où on est obligé d'expliquer à nos
concitoyens qu'on a plus de moyens qu'on
est obligé de trouver je crois pour le
département avec les baisses des
dotations ou moins 14 millions d'euros
avec l'augmentation des dépenses
sociales plus 10 millions d'objets
trouvés 24 millions et donc aux objets
nous finalement de renoncer à un certain
nombre de projets et donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas évident on se demande quel
sens de l'engagement d'un conseiller
départemental face à la montée de tous
les populismes et de la démagogie
ambiante
il est important de redonner confiance à
nos citoyens nos concitoyens il est
important de redonner de la crédibilité
à nos paroles politiques et c'est pour
ça que dans 7 ans pendant toute cette
campagne il est c'est la façon dont je
conçois la politique
eh bien je n'ai jamais fait
moindre promesse que je savais de toute
façon ne pas pouvoir tenir par la suite
et donc ce territoire moi j'y crois et
ce mandat je pense pouvoir être utile
sinon je ne serais pas engagé bien
évidemment nous avons avec sabine
drexler décidé de créer un observatoire
citoyen l'observatoire économique dans
lequel on que nous sommes un groupe
avec avec sabine et d'autres personnes
nous allons à la rencontre de nos
citoyens de nos concitoyens nous allons
à la rencontre des chefs d'entreprise
des artisans des commerçants des forces
vives économiques pourrait être cette
courroie de transmission entre les
problèmes réels que nos concitoyens
rencontre sur le terrain et les
personnes qui peuvent décider
alors quand le problème relève de la
compétence du conseil départemental nous
agissons je pense notamment aux filières
courtes 1 puisque nous pouvons agir
notamment sur ce que mange deux enfants
dans dans les cantines scolaires au
collège
ce qu'il est important de soutenir nos
agriculteurs il faut qu'ils puissent
avoir un revenu décent par rapport à une
activité qui vous c est très très
importante
et puis lorsque le problème ne relève
pas de la compétence du conseil
départemental et bien nous nous relayons
la difficulté à nos collègues qui sont
parlementaires ces députés sénateurs ou
députés européens